of the murder of roonan Kanda
you've also both pleaded guilty to the
offense of possessing a bladed article
namely a knife in a public place
I must now sentence you for those
offenses
you may remain seated until I tell you
to stand up
just after half past eight in the
evening
on the 29th of June last year
Ronan Kanda was fatally stabbed and
killed
as he was innocently walking along his
own Street back to his home
he was just yards from his front door
when he was stabbed and left to die in
the middle of the road
Ronan was only 16 years old
the devastation caused by that cowardly
Act of running up behind him and
stabbing him not once but twice is hard
to comprehend
and for his family almost too great to
bear
Ronan was much loved by all those who
are fortunate enough to know have had
him in their lives
he was a joyful young lad always intent
on making those around him happy
he was described by his friends as
always the one with the biggest smile
he was fun playful good at school and
had no enemies
we have heard this morning the powerful
and moving victim personal statements
from his father mother and sister
we have also had read to us the victim
personal statements of Ron and his uncle
and grandmother
their loss is incalculable
they described Ronan as the soul of the
family
whose loss has broken them all
chandrakanda ronan's dad says that
Roland was his best friend
a Liverpool fan who liked going to the
gym and playing pool
he describes his pride in watching run
and grow into a kind and compassionate
boy who always gave money to the
homeless and would encourage people
around him to do more for charity
he misses his son constantly
Puja Kanda Roland's mum eloquently
expressed the psychological torture she
suffers every day losing her kind and
caring son for absolutely no reason at
all
and the utter despair she feels upon
realizing that he can no longer be part
of her life
Nikita Kanda ronan's older sister speaks
lovingly of him as the glue that held
the family together
and how he deserve so much more from
life
it's no surprise that the depth of their
loss has taken its toll on their Mental
Health
with some of ronan's relatives being
treated for depression and
post-traumatic stress disorder
nothing I can say or do today
can relieve the pain of that loss
no term of years will seem sufficient
punishment to the family for your crime
no time of years will begin to
compensate the family for their loss
this case is another instance of the
national scourge of knife crime
as a result of which young lives are
brutally cut short because of the ease
with which lethal weapons can be
obtained and used on our streets
the added to tragedy in this case is
that Ronin was truly an innocent victim
he had nothing to do with gangs nothing
to do with drugs
nothing to do with violence or knives
he had no enemies
he didn't even have anyone that didn't
like him
he was just a normal 16 year old who
liked being with his friends playing
football and computer games
he didn't even have an issue with either
of you two
he was targeted by mistake
and had you not been carrying knives
that mistake would not have turned into
the unfathomable tragedy that it did
so what were the events leading up to
Roland's tragic death
both of you are at the same school as
Ronan
the Khalsa Academy in Wolverhampton
for different reasons he bought
and you requested about it
what is not in doubt is that by that
stage you did indeed have a strong
Fascination and association with knives
since about November 2021 you had been
buying knives online and selling these
on for a profit
the court was shown a sample of the
kinds of knives you purchased and resold
most were frightening even to look at
these were for the most part large
machetes and swords which have no
legitimate use on our streets
it is disturbing that a 16 year old
could so easily purchase such items
online
the businesses that engage in this kind
of trade should reflect on their
facilitation of knife crime and the
devastating consequences for the lives
of so many
you claimed that after the incident on
and posted messages on social media
flaunting the fact that he had a lot of
cash
a final demand for the money was made
for you which he did
on the 28th of June 2022 the day before
Ronan was killed you Mr Vegeta arranged
track
on the 29th of June 2022 at around 2 40
in the afternoon you must have a data
went to your local post office to
collect the knives you had ordered and
which you would use just a few hours
later to commit murder
sealed down your trouser legs a large
knife each
the arranged transport came to collect
you near your home Mr badeja at around 7
30 pm
he left the club at around quarter past
eight
his friends of course not having any
idea that that would be the last they
would ever see of him
after a few further minutes of driving
around the area you must have hadasia
asked the driver of the vehicle to stop
at the bottom of beech Road
by this time Ronan was walking back
along Mount roads to his home
he was walking away from you when you
both jumped out the car with your knives
and ran towards Ronan you must have
hadesia were in front
Ronan was wearing headphones and
listening to music
he had no idea what was about to happen
you thrust the ninja sword towards Roman
ronan's hip
Ronan stopped and turned around
you then thrust your sword again towards
Ronan this time hitting him on the chest
all of this is captured on a domestic
CCTV camera system
that system also recorded the sound
and no one who heard it will forget the
terrified scream emitted by Ronin as he
realized what had just happened
pretty and helping your injured friend
you both ran
jumped into the waiting car and sped off
leaving your friend to die on the street
passes by Sauron and called the
Emergency Services
they quickly arrived but were unable to
save him
he suffered two wounds the one to the
chest being 17 centimeters deep it cut
through ronan's heart and caused
unsurvivable blood loss
the commotion on the street led to
ronan's Dad to come and find out what
was going on
one cannot even begin to imagine his
horror at discovering that it was in
fact his own son who had just been
killed
after leaving the scene you both then
dispose of your outer clothing and the
weapons
buy or in the canal and went back to Mr
videsha's home and carried on as if
nothing had happened
you Mr shergill did inform your mother
and your uncle the next day and you
handed yourself in
it must have been an extraordinarily
difficult moment for your uncle and your
mother
to put their sense of doing the right
thing above their concern for you and
take you to the police station
the jury rejected
he murdered innocent young Ronan
by carrying a knife on the streets with
the intention of using it you've taken
away ronin's life and destroyed his
family
your actions have also ruined your own
lives and that of your own families
although of course you still have your
own lives
all of this pain
all of this grief
all of this misery
spreading beyond your families to the
whole community
could have been so easily avoided
if you have made the simple choice not
to carry knives that day
I've turned now to my approach to
sentence
you are both now 17. and we're 16 at the
time of the murder
there's only one sentence the law allows
me to pass for the offense of murder and
that is a life sentence
due to the fact that you were both under
18 when the murder was committed
the sentence is one of detention for
life at his Majesty's pleasure
I'm required to specify the minimum term
that must elapse before you can be
considered for release unlicensed by the
parole board
by schedule 21 to the sentencing act
2020 Parliament has determined the
starting point where a person takes a
knife to the scene and commits murder
for those aged over 18 when the offense
is committed the starting point for the
minimum term is 25 years
by virtue of section 127 of the police
crime sentencing and courts act 2022
which came into first under fourth on
the 28th of June last year the starting
point for offenders age 16 at the time
of the offense is 17 years detention
the fact that you both took large knives
to the scene and that Ronan was killed
means that the starting point of 17
years applies
having determined that starting point of
17 years I'm required then to take into
account the aggravating and mitigating
factors in each of your cases
of the statutory aggravating features
set out in paragraph 9 of schedule 21 to
the sentencing act 2020 the only one of
relevance here is that there was a
significant degree of planning or
premeditation
whilst Ronin may not have been the
intended victim it is clear that a
significant amount of planning went into
the attack
nice were purchased specifically for the
confrontation
whilst it's correct that you Mr Vegeta
ordered several knives from DNA Leisure
for delivery on that day there is no
doubt that at least two of them were
purchased at Mr shergill's request in
order to confront pavandeep as planned
you both took steps to wear dark hooded
clothing taking care to cover your faces
with masks
you pre-arranged transportation and
drove to various locations where you
thought your intended victim might be
the planning may not have been
particularly sophisticated
or well thought through but it was in my
judgment significant and the attack was
far from being spontaneous
Mason King's Council for the crown
suggested that a further aggravating
feature is that Ronan was particularly
vulnerable by reason of his age as he
was only 16.
whilst that might be a significant
factor in some cases
I do not consider that any particular
vulnerability was present by reason of
age in this case
you were both the same age as your
victim and any person attacked from
behind whilst walking down the street
wearing headphones would have been in as
vulnerable the position as their owner
then was
as for other aggravating features it is
notable that you both took steps to
conceal your offending you both went to
the canal together to dispose of your
weapons and outer clothing
the offense was committed on a public
Street in broad daylight
distress was caused to a number of
witnesses and bystanders
as for the statutory mitigating factors
I need to consider first whether or not
there was an intention to cause serious
bodily harm rather than an intention to
kill
in your case Mr Vegeta the prosecution
submit that I can be sure given the
nature of the weapon the fact that two
balloons were struck in quick succession
and the depth of the wounds that there
was an intent to kill
I agree with that submission
an attack with a sword as large as the
one used which is thrust first into the
victim's back hip area to a depth of 20
centimeters and then into the front of
the chest to a depth of 17 centimeters
cannot realistically be said to reveal
anything other than an intention to kill
there was no attempt here for example to
injure a less vulnerable part of the
body such as the arms or the legs or to
inflict a less penetrating injury
the wounds including the Fatal one to
the chest were caused by Deep thrusts
with a vicious weapon aimed at highly
vulnerable parts of the body
I am satisfied so that I am sure that at
the point at which you attack Ronin an
intent to kill had been formed even
though that intent
in your case Mr shergill whilst there
was a shared intention with Mr Vegeta to
do the victim at least really serious
harm
I do not find that you shared the
intention that I found Mr Vegeta had
formed at the time of the attack to kill
the victim
you were a few steps behind Mr Vegeta
did not land any blows on the victim
yourself and immediately turned around
and ran away after the attack
it was
an intention to kill in your case
the second mitigating factor is that
you're both of good character
you have no previous convictions and had
never had any involvement with the
police prior to these events
that is something that I take into
account in your favor
you have both expressed some remorse
however you both appear not to be ready
to accept full responsibility for your
actions
that is consistent with your young age
and your current level of maturity
perhaps as you mature and reflect on
what you've done during your time in
custody you will come to fully accept
your responsibility for what has
occurred
Ronan was as he acknowledged your friend
and there's been some recognition of the
pain caused by what you did
I make a small allowance for that
a further mitigating feature
to be considered is your young age
in the present case however your age has
already been taken into account in
determining the appropriate starting
point
you are not at an age that might be said
to be on the cusp of the relevant age
for a different starting point
accordingly no further allowance is made
for age
finally I take account of all that is
said in the pre-sentence reports in the
character references and what has been
said by your Council on your behalf by
way of personal mitigation
in your case Mr vidasia I note that your
father has played almost no role in your
life
you are close to your mother and younger
siblings
you were close to your grandfather and
you were deeply affected by his death a
few years ago
it is said that you felt lost after his
death death and this may have had an
effect on your behavior thereafter
notwithstanding that loss you continue
to play a positive role in the community
you've shown yourself capable of
applying yourself and I note your recent
academic and behavioral achievements
whilst in custody
there is some potential for
rehabilitation
although I must also bear in mind that
you had an unhealthy fascination
with knives and were willing to use
false ID to obtain and sell them
with no thought as to the consequences
for others
you are undoubtedly living two lives
one being that of The Good Son and the
community participant
the other being that of a minor arms
dealer completely Reckless as to the
consequences of passing on such
dangerous items to others including in
all probability other youths and
children
in your case Mr charcoal your actions
are by all accounts totally out of
character
you come from a loving stable home with
hard-working parents
you're at the heart of your family's
life in regularly volunteered at the
Gurdwara
all those who know you spoke highly of
your character and kindness
unlike Mr Vegeta that does not appear to
have been another hidden or dark sight
to your conduct
you are good at school and had much
potential to make a success of your life
but you responded all that
you've squandered that potential to make
a success of your life
by taking the decision that day to use a
knife to help you settle a dispute over
a small amount of money
the impact on your family
whilst not comparable to the devastation
course the ronin's family has been
severe
I have borne in his mind the sentencing
guidelines on sentencing children and
current conditions in prison
balancing these aggravating and
mitigating factors I've reached the
following conclusions
in your case Mr vadasia the significant
aggravating feature
of planning concealment and the location
of the offense
are balanced out to some extent by your
good character and the other mitigating
features mentioned
I consider that the minimum term
should therefore be 18 years
that is the minimum term in your case
in your case Mr shargo the additional
mitigating feature of the lack of an
intention to kill and the other
mitigating features including your good
character mean that the minimum term
should be reduced by one year
the appropriate minimum term in your
case is therefore 16 years
a deal now very briefly with the
sentence for the possession of a bladed
article
having regard to the relevant guidelines
the appropriate categorization of these
offenses is category 1A the starting
point for which is 18 months with a
range of one to two years detention
after trial
that starting point and range is for
adult Defenders over the age of 18 and
an adjustment must be made to take
account of your age
the aggravating features of planning and
concealing your identity are balanced
out by your absence of convictions
adjusting the starting point for age
that leads me to a term of 12 months
credit for your plea reduces this
further to eight months accordingly the
sentence in each of your cases for
counts two and three is eight months
which will run concurrently
will the defendants please stand
project for the murder of Ronan Kanda
are sentenced you to detention for life
at his Majesty's pleasure with a minimum
term of 18 years
for the possession of a bladed article
are sentenced due to eight months
detention to run concurrently
from the minimum term of 18 years they
must be deducted
the 375 days you have spent on remand
and custody for this offense
the minimum term is accordingly 18 years
less the 375 days
foreign for the murder of Ronan Kanda I
sentenced you to detention for life at
his Majesty's pleasure with a minimum
term of 16 years
for the possession of the pleated
article a sentence you also to eight
months detention to run concurrently
from the minimum term of 16 years must
be deducted the 375 days you have spent
on demand and custody for this offense
the minimum term
accordingly is 16 years less 375 days
the victim surcharge muscle to be paid
in both cases
it's important to emphasize so that you
and all those who are listening and
viewing this sentence
can understand the position the minimum
term is just that
a minimum period which cannot be reduced
in any way
after your respective minimum terms are
served there is no guarantee that you
will be released at that time or at any
particular time thereafter
it is only if the parole board decides
that you're no longer a danger to
society
and fit to be released that you will you
will be released
that will not be before you have served
every day of your minimum term
even if you are released after serving
your minimum term
you will remain subject to license for
the rest of your life
that means you may be recalled to
continue your life sentence at any time
if considered appropriate
it is in these ways that a life sentence
with a minimum term protects the public
for the future
that concludes my sentence you may take
them down